- All right y'all, before we say goodbye,
let's take a quick dive into
the world of social media.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
So earlier, the cast of
"Shucked" impressed us all
with their vocal talents.
It was so amazing, but there
is another little Broadway star
impressing people online,
this time through crocheting.
I know.
This is 12-year-old Michael.
His crafting skills are
the star of his Instagram.
He crochets everything from
shirts to blankets to hats,
and you will never guess who taught him.
Tony award-winning Broadway
actress Sutton Foster
actually taught him to crochet,
which I think is amazing.
Let's get this little
crochet star in here.
Watching on NBC New York,
say hi to Michael, everybody.
(audience cheering and clapping)
What's up, Michael?
- Hi Kelly, how are you?
- Oh my God, I am so excited.
Did you make your shirt?
- Yes, I did.
I actually made it in a movie this summer
before the strike.
- Oh, you look so great. Oh my gosh.
So, Sutton Foster taught you, right?
Like, how did that happen?
- So, I was on "Music Man"
on Broadway last year,
and backstage we were all
a little rambunctious.
So Sutton Foster, the legendary actress,
taught us how to crochet.
And I always remember this one time
where I crocheted this blanket.
It was wonky, it was horrible,
I don't even know what I did,
but I took it to Sutton
and she was so proud
and she said it was great.
But then when I got home,
I really looked at it,
and I was like, "This woman
deserves a Tony, an Oscar."
She was the best actress I knew
because that blanket
was horrible. (laughs)
- No, I will say one time
I gave some of the coaches
at "The Voice," when I worked
on there, quilts that I made.
They were sad if you looked closely.
But if you were far
away, it was like, "Oh."
So we have one of Michael's pieces.
This is a cardigan that he
crocheted and I wanted to...
This is so cool.
How long did this take?
- So it took around four to five days,
but the challenge was like the design.
So I chose that hot pink because
it fits your personality.
You're sassy, fun, and I chose-
- Wait, what do you mean my personality?
Is this for me?
- Yes.
- Oh!
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Well, thank you.
- And if you look on the back, it says-
- Oh.
- MC X KC
'cause that's the ultimate collab.
- Oh, I love it.
This is so sweet.
I'm gonna wear this around here.
Oh, it's right there. (gasps)
I love you so much, Michael.
Thank you so much.
- I love you too.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- All right, everybody.
So Michael, I'm liking
your post right now,
but that's not all, okay?
Our season-long...
Oh, this is cozy and warm. All right, son.
Okay, our season-long partner-
- Thank you.
- Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly, just like you,
so they're gonna give you
$1,000 just for being rad.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Thank you so much.
- And your shirt is so cool.
That sweater's so cool, man.
Thank you so much, Michael.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Mario Lopez, Shane McAnally,
Grey Henson, John Behlmann,
the cast of "Shucked," they're incredible.
Dave, hilarious, Annie
Starke and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day and
until tomorrow, (indistinct).